Yingling which is a great beer Yingling
tweets out nice picture of a can of
Yingling lager right in front of an
American flag with a sunrise right buff
behind it says Yingling the oldest
brewery in America independently owned
family operated since 1829 because we
make good beer this is really beautiful
corporate shade being thrown and it's
being thrown in a very traditionally
American way this is very waspy the
Wasps the founding stock of America
probably they're defining characteristic
is their subtlety they don't they don't
show boat they're very they keep things
fairly bottled up very dry kind of humor
that's what you're seeing here Yingling
we're independently owned and operated
yeah we just kind of support America and
make good beer oh just what oh what did
Bud Light do oh I didn't I must not have
heard about that okay yeah anyway we
just make really this is this is the way
this is the way this is this is the best
response I've seen so far to the Bud
Light controversy